think everybody who's been involved in
the uh
in the the vaccination program can be
incredibly proud of what has been
achieved and i i thank all kinds of
people
obviously i thank the the scientists who
came up with the the vaccines i thank
the
the the people who've got it all
together they
organized it but if you look at what's
happened in the last few weeks
it's been an unbelievable effort by
the nhs and the doctors the nurses the
the gp surgeries the hospitals of course
the the army has been fantastic the
pharmacists have done
a great job they've been assisted by
legions of
volunteers but i think one of the the
most striking things about the uk
vaccination effort has been the
centrality of
of gp surgeries of uh of the nhs
and they've they've done the lion's
share of the work and it's been
really very moving to see it if there's
anybody at all in the 70-plus category
who thinks that they're hanging off with
a jab
i don't really know of any um that there
are any
what should they do of course the
numbers are very good for the over 80s
for
the over 70s and you know i think 75 79
group you're looking at 99 that have
been done but there are some people who
have still had to come forward and i
really do urge people to come forward
these
uh these jabs these vaccines are are
safe they're efficacious
they they will help protect you against
disease and
against against against death and
they're they're a wonderful thing to
have help protect you your family
your neighbors and i think people get
that and that's why they're coming
forward in such numbers but
if you haven't yet had a letter and you
you think that
you you you need one uh and you think
that you you're in the in the in the
categories
concerned get on to the nhs or
or dial 119 and and we'll fix you up
with a jab
now you can't say too much today about
the future in terms of lockdown lifting
but the one thing that we seem to be
being told by lots of people in
whitehall is that you will attempt
to open schools all as one primary and
secondary schools all at the same time
possibly march the 8th if the data
allows rather than staggering that can
you just confirm that one thing for us
well no decisions have been taken on
on that sort of with that sort of detail
yet
sam though clearly schools on march the
8th has for
a long time been a priority of the
government and of
families up and down the country uh
we'll do everything we can
to to to make that happen but we've got
to keep looking
at the data we've got to keep looking at
the rates of infection don't forget
they're still very high
still 23 000 or so in
copy patients in the nhs more than at
the april peak
last year still sadly uh too many people
dying
of this disease rates of infection
although they're coming down
are still comparatively high so we've
got to be very
prudent and what we want to see
is progress that is cautious
but irreversible i think that's what the
public and
and people up and down the country will
want to see progress that is cautious
but irreversible as you go into this
week where you study the data and work
out what you're going to do next can you
just
say a bit about about your approach you
want to drive down infection rates you
want to protect the nhs
but once they're low and the
vulnerability have been vaccinated
what do you do then is it okay for the
virus to circulate amongst the 20s 30s
and 40s
do you learn to live with coronavirus
like flu as matt hancock was saying at
the weekend
well that's a very interesting question
i think the we would like to see
the the rates of infection come down
very low indeed and that's why we have
the tough border regimes to stop uh
infection
coming in and as we get ever better with
with testing
and tracing and enforcing uh
fights against the new variants uh we
want to see that those rates really
really low because
the risk is that if you have a large as
it were
volume of circulation if you've got
loads of people even
young people getting the disease and a
couple of things happen
first of all you have a higher risk of
new variants of mutations
within the population where the disease
is
circulating secondly there will also be
a greater risk of the disease spreading
out
into the older groups again and although
the vaccines are effective and and great
of course no vaccination program is 100
effective and so when you have a large
volume of circulation we've got
a lot of disease inevitably the
vulnerable
will will suffer so that's why we wanted
to drive it right down
keep it right down you're going to set
out more on monday about lifting
lockdown can you tell us what kinds of
decisions you'll be making then for
instance
will you be giving us dates for when
things will reopen
sam if we possibly can we'll be we'll be
setting out
dates and just to help people think
about the what we're trying to do on the
on the 22nd
remember what we did in uh around about
this time
last year a little bit later we set out
a road map going forward into the
into the summer and looking a little bit
beyond that's what we're going to be
trying to do the dates that we'll be
setting out
will be the dates by which we hope we
can do something
at the earliest if you saw what i mean
so that's the
it's the target date by which we hope to
do something at the earliest
if because of uh the
rate of infection we have to push
something off a little bit
to the right delay it for a little bit
we won't
hesitate to do that i think people would
much rather see
a plan that was cautious but
irreversible and one that proceeds
sensibly in accordance with where we are
with the disease
okay finally vaccine passports the
bottom line is
that companies are going to require
proof that
people have been vaccinated foreign
countries might require proof that
you've had the vaccine in order to let
you in
you're not going to stop companies and
countries doing that and then in the end
you're going to end up facilitating that
process aren't you
i think inevitably there will be a
great interest in ideas like uh can you
show that you've had a vaccination
against
covet in the way that you sometimes you
have to show that you've had a
vaccination
against yellow fever or or other
diseases in order to travel somewhere i
think that's going to be
very much in the in the mix uh down the
road i think that that is going to
to happen i don't what i don't think we
will have in this country is as it were
uh vaccination uh passports to allow you
to go to say the pub or something like
that i think that that would be
uh going it a bit i think if to just
looking at the
the future what we hope to have is such
a high proportion
of the population vaccinated
that when you couple that with uh
rapid testing lateral flow testing you
really start to get
the kind of answer that you're you're
talking about so i think it's in the
in the context of a really uh having
vaccinated
a lot of the of the population as we're
already doing
and we'll do a lot more of in the next
few months at the the rapid
test approach will start i think to come
into its own